we
hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Ramiro javi and I just want to thank you
very much for the overwhelming interest
that you've shown in my my my proposal I
didn't think that today I will be
presenting and but here am i and I just
did the I am sorry for the crappy
presentation because I just did it in
the last hour and okay so I am from I
just came to Germany like before five
years five five months ago and and I
came exactly from the city of Aleppo
which is the heart of the world that's
going on right now as you as you know
and this is my city it's a lovely City
before the war I don't know why I told
you it's presentation okay
and this is our like awesome great
castle of Aleppo and this is my city
right now after the war as you see it
it's totally destroyed also here again
but I'm not showing you those photos -
like - because every time I read an
article regarding refugees the the guys
that make our write those articles they
are like really like most of the time
they are really sweet and awesome but
they tend to tell stories that are
emotional and sentimental just to make
the people you know feel sorry this is
not my intention at all and to be
bluntly honest I really don't like it
when somebody comes at me and just and
just speaks in a like his feels like
really sorry so I don't want you to feel
sorry but I actually my intention was
maybe and hopefully to change the way
you look and see refugees here in
Germany as you may there is a lot of as
you may have known
there's a lot of controversy regarding
the refugees that the huge amount of
images that are coming to Germany and I
just hope by giving this representation
to make make you maybe feel like the
refugees can be a can be a huge
opportunity for Germany and if they are
put in the right use and they can really
help push the economic wheel of this
really awesome country that I literally
fallen in love with over the last five
months and I really like consider it as
my second home right now
well so you saw the the the photos of my
city Aleppo so I you may think like here
you know the it's not a five star living
there is no electricity so if you are a
programmer I guess you need some
electricity too but there is no
electricity at all and you can't Google
anything and most of the work that I do
is always googling stuff because that's
the way how I work and I think most of
you guys also work the same so there is
no electricity there is no water and you
have to do like every I I used to hate
this like every morning I have to go and
just bring water from a place where
there is so many people but I have to
find a way to come where there is not so
many people and just bring water for
this day and mmm I told you so I mean
there is no if you see there's no
internet and there is no water but what
was I doing there
I stayed there actually I was there in
Aleppo when the war actually started
when I was 17 years old I was there we
have you know like this at the last year
of high school where you have to be do
this big exam in Syria and you have to
study really really hard for like one
year so if you want to get into a good
faculty so at this time when I was
preparing for this because I want you to
you know to study informatics
engineering and you have to bring very
high marks so you can get into this
faculty in Syria and just so you know
actually many people in Syria many
attendees of the informatics faculty are
our woman here in Berlin I'm right now
guest student in Berlin and it's the
opposite most of them are guys so I
don't expect that so what was I doing I
was playing games most of the time like
those two just switching between the
richer and the GTA and so this and I was
learning at the University C++ object
oriented programming and Java and some
algorithms but we were learning so many
theoretical stuff like dirt math linear
algebra probabilities all of those crazy
stuff and I really as you may think I
didn't enjoy them very well because you
see nothing you just abstract so Unreal
Engine came out at the same time I was
studying those things in Syria where we
had internet for life I guess I was
lucky at the summer we had internet it
was really slow but it was okay so the
Unreal Engine 4 was introduced and I had
I was reading I wanted to apply the C++
so I read about 3d stuff like maybe
using unity or Unreal Engine but then
Unreal Engine 1 because he is using a C+
so I try to make games that I thought I
can make a triple a game maybe like Mass
Effect alone and in three months well I
guess that didn't work very well and
yeah so I made a little game do you like
the zombies took out our our University
and you're gonna have to try to kick
them out the the characters didn't have
really a good look because but it was ok
it worked fine and yeah I was just at
that time of the world people outside
are fighting I was playing GTA was funny
because the voices are mixed some voices
you hear from outside and some voices
from GTA and its really good quite quite
sounds good sound effects and like I
didn't have those 3d like speed
supporters but it was really cool like
when you hear the blue it's really like
a huge boom so that was the way I was
spending my time and like going to
learning math learning some Java and
staying at home watching The Walking
Dead Game of Thrones and playing those
games and developing Unreal Engine so
that's what I was doing then one day I
was there at university we always used
to go to the architecture faculty
because there most of the hot girls and
hot guys they go all there and they
would try to meet each other and you
know do whatever they want to do and so
one of my friends we were there sitting
like just checking this girl out and
then he tells me well you know actually
I have this crazy idea we should get out
of here like we weren't doing nothing in
Aleppo I don't know what do you mean
what do what we are doing some stuff he
told me well well we can do something
better here in Europe and he is like
that that time no no no refugees like
this huge amount of people were coming
and nobody knew about this idea so I
thought he was stupid like I'm in Syria
I'm gonna go and just go what I'm gonna
make take a visa or just what I'm gonna
I'm gonna fly take a rocket I can't come
here this is impossible he is crazy yeah
I didn't give give him much attention
and then after two months he comes to me
and tells me I'm gonna say goodbye to
you right now I'm gonna try my luck and
I'm gonna go to Germany but tell him
really and I I took it as a laughs I
think he's gonna come back maybe in one
week and he'll have spent so much money
on nothing and he'll lately later regret
but in 30 days he is in Germany he is
taking photos in Berlin so that was
really like a huge shock to me that was
as you may have mentioned that was
before all of those crazy people were
coming and millions and millions of I
don't know if refugees were coming and
it's all over the news that was all
before that so I started like he put
this idea in my mind and I started
asking my parents as you know I was when
I started asking them I was 20 right now
in 21 so I like I need I can you I want
to go to Germany you know what are you
talking about just just yeah just get
past the eyeliner algebra and then we'll
talk about it and then
and then summer car came and so many
people were the news everybody we're
talking about how all of those people
are all of those refugees are coming to
Europe and they were like so awesome
here like as you see our Europe is
without borders and then this refugees
welcome stuff so the idea wasn't really
that crazy then my father started you
know thinking about it one of you huge
one of the huge barriers also was the
money because you needed my father is a
lawyer
but you know right now there is no law
in Syria I guess and a lawyer wouldn't
work as well as before you know this
destruction I wasn't living there I was
living here in the same city but it is
you know separated so I was I was lucky
and to be living in a another part of
the city that is more fortunate that it
is a bit more safe so to say like only
one rocket today and then then he
actually agreed I don't know how like as
I'm okay you need maybe two thousand
dollars to to make the trip and then he
agreed and then I told him can I take my
brother because my brother with me he
told me now if you want to try this you
will try this on your own and before he
changed my mind I just did I took
everything I packed my stuff and I was
out and I didn't believe it I thought
like Oh God really then I took the the I
got out of Syria which was really the
hardest part the sea was nothing I also
I told my father actually one of the way
that I I convinced him I told him if you
don't let me go I'm gonna go just
because you know the most money was
gonna go to the guys that put you in
this boat like 1200 for them so if you
don't want to give me the money just
give me less I will go swimming I'm a
really good swimmer eyes in five guys
five five hours a day I can go swimming
you can see I mean the island it's just
over there and I guess he
and then after you get to Greece you
start you know sneaking across the
borders and just getting a country of
three country and then after 15 16 days
I'm here in Berlin
well I didn't come to Berlin at first I
didn't think I'd come to Germany I was
at Austria and then I thought oh well
I'm like in Germany right now which city
I mean I'm gonna be living right so Iowa
I stayed in Vienna for actually three
days thinking which city and then I came
up with Hannover at first so I I went to
Hanover and I got up to the of the bus
station and it was just two minutes
actually I don't know I didn't like it
and then I go back to them and I just I
just go I just call my my brother I tell
you man I didn't like any over well what
buddy where do you think he is 16 years
old by the way and he what do you think
I should go well he told people you
can't go wrong by with Berlin okay if
you say so then I'm gonna be taking this
train to Berlin right now and you know
nobody thought that I would be in Berlin
and then and none of my friends you know
I didn't even know what that but then I
post on Facebook I check in in Berlin
and so much some of my friends PM me
like and we are here also we should meet
up there's nobody this is like how did
you come to Berlin at a limit how did
you come to Berlin like you just were
there in Aleppo and we just have a
semester Farion and semester and you are
here right now in Berlin well that's
weird and then I'm I got registered
and then I got registered with I had to
go through the crazy experience of of
trying to register myself as a refugee
ask for to register myself with
alligator and I guess West Berlin in
Berlin is really awesome as you all may
know it's really it's just crazy I had
to like I think two weeks just to try to
tell them back hey guys I'm refugee just
just stickers type something nobody
knows I'm here in Berlin nobody knows
that I am here and then I have and then
I am sitting so what should I do now
right now I'm in Berlin like I didn't
plan this much this this long right now
what am i what am I going to do right
now I am I used to study informatics in
the Faculty of Aleppo what am I going to
do here and I don't know the language
well thank God I know I watched Game of
Thrones and Walking Dead and I learned
some English instead of argument and so
I had to do the obvious thing and try to
learn German and well this is just a
joke yes yet if I steal guns good
Deutsche ba exists all finished
zu good Wow her Science Nouveau for to
Oberlin
well thank you but it is really hope
it's it's not good okay
my you can ask my teacher she will tell
you and then well learning German German
would take much of your time but my my
passion I didn't come to Germany just to
learn German I want to continue
programming so but I didn't have I had a
really cool rig back in Syria I got a
computer like with GPU GTX I don't know
what I forgot 560 it was really good rig
but here I don't have a laptop and I
don't have a PC I'm not gonna take my
rig with me in the boat and just come
over here so I thought about it I
thought about it it's a really good
drink but they would take much money to
bring it it would be a person so a good
friend of mine that that I got to know
orange and Berlin just two weeks after
three weeks and I'm in Berlin she sends
me a message or sends my friend a
message and then he sends me the message
there she says that there is this new
school it's called ready school which
will give laptops for for you guys and
for everybody not only mostly refugees
it will give you laptops they're not the
best laptops this is their laptop that
they give me that they gave me and they
will teach you programming if you are if
you already know some programming there
is an advanced course and if you are
total beginner there is a beginner
course so I say well I don't think that
they're gonna give me a laptop but I
will go I have only German I will go
there and try my luck so I go and after
two months they opened the school it was
really just the beginning they were just
far they are trying to figure the idea
that school is going to work and they
decided to teach us Ruby on Rails
and they made a good argument about it
and I said well you're going to teach us
to be on wheels it's okay and we go we
start learning Ruby on Rails and they
bring mentors you know the mentors
they're gonna they are volunteers that
just wanna spread the knowledge and then
there is this - guys the what - every
time there is a mentor every like there
is different mentor we have three
classes a week and this mentor thinks
meteor is better and thinks JavaScript
is better and his name is Peter and he
instead he he tells the people at the
school we are learning Ruby on Rails but
in the in the session we are learning
JavaScript I mean I mean when I when she
asked they asked me the like hey so how
is it going with you guys with the Ruby
on Rails
well I we are learning JavaScript well
really well we have to talk with this
guy and then I got him fired no no no
I'm just kidding and yeah so I liked
JavaScript actually more than Ruby on
Rails and I really enjoyed meteor
because you can make stuff very fast and
see the results in front of you and the
my first project or no not now I will
talk about later so as I became a member
of this school I we had a lot of fun we
did really amazing stuff we talked at
Cisco live and this is an we presented
together at Cisco live Berlin this year
2016 and we talked about what we've done
at the at the course and how is like the
school working and stuff and it was
really an amazing presentation but then
mr. Mark Zuckerberg was at Berlin and
before the day before it
I was sleeping late like I don't sleep
late but I was sleeping late till 3:00
p.m. like really really late and then I
wake up and I check my
phone and I see like it's exploding with
messages and like many people are
calling me and I don't get those kind of
messages and calls on normal day and
then I like I I am really sleepy I just
yeah what do you want guys what is wrong
everybody is just calling me well you're
gonna meet somebody tomorrow and we're
not gonna tell you who is I didn't know
Mark Zuckerberg was there you're gonna
meet somebody - it's true he's
really like influential and stuff and I
thought I'm gonna be meeting miracle or
somebody I don't know and then but so I
go and I asked a friend of mine in there
ad school they didn't tell me I just
told them like tell me Who am I gonna
meet so I prepare myself no we can't if
you tell you that it will not happen so
I asked a friend of mine who is also in
the and the school and she knows and she
told me yeah I don't tell anybody but
it's gonna be Mark Zuckerberg and then
III tell everybody and I didn't even met
him and it may not work but like I have
been calling everybody even in Syria
like people in new yellow man I think
I'm gonna be meeting Mark Zuckerberg
tomorrow well they told me not to see
anybody so please don't tell anybody so
and then he's telling other people so on
the next day actually all of this talk
they didn't get this and I met him and
we had a good talk about virtual reality
and about like if I asked him the normal
question that everybody asks him should
I continue college and stuff like
regarding that he didn't and yeah it was
a good half an hour and we discussed
many stuff like JavaScript a thing that
I'm the stuff and that I'm learning and
Unreal Engine and he yes and he actually
told me to use it's a good idea to use
Unreal Engine to develop stuff for the
VR and then this is a crazy photo of me
well I thought I was then working on
meteor to make a site for the already
school it's not deployed or saw anything
I just was doing at trying to you like
better
my knowledge using the JavaScript and
meteor and I I don't know why I did I
think that one laptop wasn't enough and
I don't know and actually my friend also
the one who is helping me thought the
same thing that one laptop ain't enough
and so we actually made a media website
that has you know like registration and
user interface and like a profile pages
for everybody is like a mini Facebook
and in use feed and stuff using MongoDB
and Ruby JavaScript and meat here and it
was actually good for like I did it in
actually three weeks just refreshing my
memories about the pay basics and then
learning the meteor and JavaScript and
MongoDB because I have no idea about
databases and we made the side the
source is not is not pretty but it works
and then before two days ago
we were having a discussion with well 20
and 24 we were going to also make a
webpage on their side like not whole
page menus many web pages like it's a
mini site in their site
- yeah using javascript and using meat
here and I will be also continuing
studying at tio Berlin and trying to
learn I'm not studying like I am right
now you know trying to learn the
language I understand many like 60% e %
of the what's the professor is saying
but I still need more and I will not be
official until I have a certain level so
that's the stuff that I'm gonna be doing
and thank you guys very much for your
patience and letting me giving me the
chance to present this this story and I
hope that you liked it and if you have
any I don't know
we have yeah we still have time I guess
I thought it would take more yeah if you
have any questions or anything I'd be
happy to answer them or try to answer
them
like
well this is actually the first time I
hear is that human because I wouldn't be
given a visa or anybody I mean I'm not a
super techy guy but maybe I will earn
fast I guess but regarding the second
question I know that there is like
43,000 job opportunities for programmers
here in Germany that are not fulfilled
and they need anybody who who can do
this any job and I so like many people
came to our many companies came to our
school and they asked us and we are
still learning and the ask has just come
you will learn on the job well it's not
well what do you think so many the
system is not working I guess very well
when because I think there is many
refugees that are coming but I mean I
did I don't have a residency until now
nobody like many people who don't know
don't can't can't speak English can't
program anything can't do anything
they got the residency they are just
like me also from Syria or other
countries I think they are refugees they
got the residency and now they can go to
the do any place to work or anything but
I'm I can work actually do actual work
but I I'm not allowed to work so this is
the the problem like I'm not allowed to
work and I am NOT also given any
residency and what was the first
yeah so many people is there many guys
just like me yes there is many guys but
they're in the shadows because many
doctors are living in camps I saw many
doctors that are ready just to work with
it many engineers the mechanical
engineers many many many people with
educated they are already finished there
they have their degree with them they
are ready as our school and but they
didn't like they didn't get any help or
any or any like nobody helped them they
they were helped but they didn't get the
residency to help Germany to help the
economic wheel that's the problem and
there is many people yes there is a I'm
not gonna I want to be very honest I'm
not going to tell you all those all the
refugees that came they are really
educated they are like no no not all of
them and the majority are not I want to
be honest but not everybody not
everybody that came here needs to be a
tech guy or needs to be a doctor or
needs to they can work any other job to
just to not be a burden on Germany to
not keep on taking money I don't like
taking money from the government but
they will not let me work and other
people would like to work but they are
by they didn't learn the language this
is their fault and they didn't get
offered to learn a language that's all
so I think maybe the government is full
if there is any I hope I answered your
question